ATTORNEYS MAY TRY TO USE OUR LAX
ASYLUM LAWS TO FORCE US TO TAKE
IN HUNDREDS OF THESE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, CONDUCTING SEMINARS
AND SO FORTH.
FOR REACTION, WE ARE JOINED BY
CONGRESSMAN STEVE KING OF IOWA,
MEMBER OF AN IMMIGRATION AND
BORDER SECURITY SUBCOMMITTEE AND
CONGRESS.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU, BUT THIS
IS DISTURBING.
THIS IS JUST WILD WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
YOU HAVE THESE LAWYERS,
INCLUDING THIS GUY WHO WAS ONE
OF THE LEAD LAWYERS IN THIS
EFFORT, ALEX MENSING, A PROJECT
COORDINATOR ORGANIZING THIS
EFFORT TO HELP THE CARAVAN.
THE CONCERN, CONGRESSMEN, IS
THAT WE HAVE AMERICAN LAWYERS
AND OTHER NONGOVERNMENTAL
HAND IN GLOVE, DE FACTO, WITH
MEDIA OUTLETS TO PUSH, MEXICAN
ELECTION COMING UP IN A FEW
MONTHS.
PUT THE POLITICAL PRESSURE ON
MEXICO AND AS I SAID, KEEP IT
ALL GOING.
THEY MAKE THEIR WAY TO TIJUANA
AND THEN WALKED?
>> SEEING THIS CARAVAN MAKE ITS
WAY TOWARDS THE UNITED STATES
ENDEAVOR TOWARDS TIJUANA AND
SEEING THE WAY THEY ARE
FACILITATING THIS WITH THE MEDIA
AND WITH THE IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEYS, I WISH THE
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY
ORGANIZATION HAS AT LEAST 15,000
MEMBERS IN THE UNITED STATES.
OF THAT ORGANIZATION.
THERE IS FEDERAL STATUTES THAT
PROHIBIT AND ARE A FELONY FOR
CONTRIBUTING AND AIDING AND
ABETTING ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THEY BETTER HAVE THEIR LAWS
RIGHT IF THEY'RE GOING TO GO TO
A FOREIGN COUNTRY AND HELP
FACILITATE AN UNARMED INVASION
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
WE ARE WEAK ON OUR ASYLUM LAWS.
THAT IS HOW THE LAW WAS PASSED
BY VOICE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT AFTER EVERYBODY LEFT FOR
THE AIRPORT FOR CHRISTMAS
VACATION.
A FEW YEARS AGO.
SEVERAL YEARS, I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT YEAR.
I READ THE TEXT OF THAT AND THEY
WERE READY TO GAMBLE OUT AND
EVERYBODY HEADED TO THE AIRPORT
AND IT WAS SET UP TO BE, THIS
WAS DURING THE PELOSI ERA WHEN
SHE WAS THE SPEAKER AND WHEN
HARRY REID --
>> Laura: LET ME EXPLAIN TO
PEOPLE.
YOU CLAIM ASYLUM WHEN YOU SAY
YOU HAVE A CREDIBLE FEAR OF
PERSECUTION FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
IT'S REALLY LAX.
YOU CAN -- RACE, RELIGION,
NATIONALITY, MEMBERSHIP IN A
PARTICULAR SOCIAL GROUP.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
AND POLITICAL OPINION.
SOME OF US FEEL PERSECUTED FOR
HAVING A POLITICAL OPINION HERE.
ON THOSE GROUNDS COMMITTEE CAN
CLAIM ASYLUM.
OVERWHELMINGLY, THE IMMIGRATION
JUDGES HAVE GRANTED ASYLUM OR
ALLOWED PEOPLE TO BE RELEASED.
THEN THEY NEVER COME BACK FOR
THEIR HEARING OR DEPORTATION
BRIEFING.
>> TRAINING THEM WHAT TO SAY SO
WHEN THEY ARRIVE --
>> Laura: WORKSHOPS.
THEY ARE DOING WORKSHOPS WITH
THESE MIGRANTS.
>> I STOOD ON A CLIFF OUTSIDE OF
ROMA, TEXAS, AND WATCHED THEM
INFLATE THE RAFT, BRING A
PREGNANT LADY ACROSS.
THEY BROUGHT IT TO THE SHORE AND
THE GRASS, HELPED HER UP, HANDED
HER BAGS OF HER POSSESSIONS AND
SHE STOOD AND WAITED FOR THE
BORDER PATROL TO COME ALONG TO
CLAIM CREDIBLE FEAR.
>> Laura: WHY HAVEN'T
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS DONE
ANYTHING TO CHANGE THIS LAW?
YOU HAVE BEEN A STAUNCH LOG
STRENGTHENING IMMIGRATION LAWS.
NONCONTIGUOUS COUNTRIES, OTHER
HONDURAS, EL SALVADOR,
CENTRAL AMERICA AND BEYOND.
IF THEY SHOW UP AT OUR BORDER
AND THEY THROW THEMSELVES AT A
BORDER PATROL AGENT, THEY DON'T
HAVE TO CROSS THE BORDER.
JUST SHOW UP.
THEY CAN GET ASYLUM IN THE
UNITED STATES VERY EASILY OR AT
LEAST BE RELEASED INTO THE
UNITED STATES EASILY.
WE MUST HAVE A NEW LAW THAT SAYS
YOU CAN BE EXPEDITIOUSLY AND
IMMEDIATELY REMOVED BACK TO YOUR
COUNTRY, LIKE YOU ARE IF YOU ARE
A MEXICAN.
MEXICANS DON'T HAVE THAT
ABILITY.
ONLY OTHER THAN MEXICANS HAVE
THAT ABILITY TO BE RELEASED BACK
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S NUTS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS JUDGE IN
D.C. PART OF THE JUDICIAL
TYRANNY.
>> CHANGING THE CREDIBLE FEAR
LANGUAGE, WE DID A TOUR OF THE
BORDER LAST OCTOBER WITH
CHAIRMAN BOB GOODLATTE AND
OTHERS.
WE WENT THROUGH A SUPPORT
SYSTEM.
WE SAW A LOT OF WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
THE SIMPLE CHANGES WRITTEN INTO
A LOT OF ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS
IN IT.
HE >> Laura: WHERE IS THAT?
SPEAK OF THIS ACT IS LOOKING FOR
A WAY TO COME TO THE FLOOR.
>> Laura: PAUL RYAN, HE'S NOT
GOING TO BRING INTO THE FLOOR
QUESTION         ?
>> SOME REPUBLICANS INSIST ON
DACA AMNESTY.
>> Laura: HERE WE GO.
YOU CANNOT JUST DO SOMETHING
THAT PROTECTS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THAT PROTECTS OUR SOVEREIGNTY,
OUR BORDERS, OUR HEALTH, OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
YOU CAN'T JUST DO THAT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WITHOUT A BIG
GIVEAWAY TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
IS THAT CORRECT?
PEOPLE WATCHING THIS, THEY WANT
TO THROW SOMETHING.
I DO, AND I AM HOSTING THE SHOW.
>> THE PRESIDENT WHOM I SUPPORT,
PROMISED HE WOULD END DACA BUT
HE SERVED UP DACA AMNESTY.
>> Laura: I DON'T TALK ABOUT
THAT.
THAT DROVE ME CRAZY.
SPEAK WHAT I'M SAYING IS WE
SHOULD MAKE A DEAL BETWEEN THE
RULE OF
LAW AND AMNESTY.
>> Laura: I CAN CAN LATELY
AGREE 13,186.
13,186 UAM, UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
UNDER 17 HAVE ALREADY BEEN
RELEASED THIS YEAR IN
FISCAL YEAR 2018.
>> I CAN GUARANTEE THEY WERE
DRIVEN TO, BUST TO, OR FLOW TO
ALL 50 STATES.
RECORDS SHOW --
>> THEY MADE GO TO AN ADDRESS IN
LAS VEGAS.
WHO KNOWS.
COULD BE A COYOTE HOUSE.
COULD BE A DRUG SMUGGLING HOUSE.
MS-13.
I WAS IN ARIZONA.
THEY BUSTED HIM FOR A PICKUP
LOAD OF MARIJUANA.
240 POUNDS.
HE HAD A TATTOO ON HIS ARM.
I SAW WITH MY EYES.
WE UNLOADED THAT MARIJUANA.
IT'S A STUNNING THING WHEN YOU
PUT YOUR EYES ON IT YOU WALK IN
THE WAREHOUSES AND GOING TO
THOSE JAILS.
ABOUT 81% MALE BY THE DATA I'M
LOOKING AT.
SOME OF THOSE YOUTH HAVE A
LITTLE GRAY IN THEIR BEARD,